what's that party people
welcome to honest trailer commentaries
for the Oscars 2018 this is the third
time we've done an Oscars on his trailer
and I'm sure not the last I'm Spencer
Shay Gilbert here with me is Joe star
and Dan Morelle hello and we saw pretty
much all that Dan definitely saw all of
these movies I saw probably seven out of
nine and you know it's a it's a good
crop good crop this year yeah I like
doing this cuz it's we get to do a
little 30-second micro trailers for
movies that we mostly would never do an
honest trailer for there's a lot of
these movies if you ever wonder what the
honest trailer like for Dunkirk for
example like what you didn't to make an
honest trailer for cuz it's like when
you say
yeah that's the distal thing that's the
distilled version of what the honest
trailer for Dunkirk would mean you get
to you get it in this yeah there you go
yeah they're little little quick hits
and there's usually one oscar movie that
gets its own full-fledged run this year
it was get out yep we've done the rabbit
got one those two years ago last year I
don't know I'm sure we did one of the
vets someone will check it down I
remember the revenue when we said yeah
so but really this year is like a really
solid crop of movies and it kind of
takes some of the drama out of the
Oscars because like I'm not mad if any
of these Wayne anything like they're all
good yeah darkest hour one nothing
against darkest hour I just kind of
thought it was very real HBO good if
darkest hour one I'd be like yeah but
just about any other one I would I would
be you know even if you know I wasn't
while I liked it I didn't flip out over
Dunkirk but if it won best picture I
would at least be like okay I get it
yeah it was like the best in theater
experience exactly sure yeah
there's some years that the one that
wins I'm like really okay whatever
I wish darkest hour had been a comedy
that was my big takeaway oh I really
wish he had just that had just been
played for wacky fat suit laughs and
it's like rolling down stairs
everything else is serious around it and
I would have given that my Best Picture
vote Joe you write that you make that
happen
donut honest our own oh yeah so I don't
know it's tough to talk about this as a
whole so why don't we just teach one of
them and pause it and give her thoughts
one but one one number one
it's time once again for the Oscars
Hollywood's annual award show for the
best films released between late
November and late December hold on get
out get out get out and 3-ball Birds was
technically a fall release Lady Bird was
technically a fall release but that's
probably like limited and then it goes
wide it goes wide later
yeah like most of these were hitting
theaters wide around late November yes
most people see them around like the
memory not really Janie especially bad
if I remember correctly where it was
definitely all in that time frame yeah
well which is sad because so many good
movies I remember last year was a my
name is Doris this year it was Logan a
good time I'm just gonna say yes but
there's always like a really good movie
that comes out in February or March that
that just gets forgotten about yeah
Dunkirk was summer get out was what get
out was before last year's Oscars that's
definitely the outlier for this year as
far as release dates but yeah it is
generally a celebration of movies that
come out and inner part of the year
Oscar season yes Aaron carrion only one
of these nine films will win the coveted
title of best picture unless the guy in
charge of the result screws up because
he was on his phone backstage and the
this is not a joke moonlight is won Best
Picture best Oscars ever cause if you
want to there's a great I read of this
yesterday I think it's a variety or
Hollywood Reporter they ran an oral
history of that basically breaking it
down and it is in credit wound like the
guy had been warned like every they had
wore it like people had already said
this guy needs to stay off his phone and
they told him to stay off he'd been
warned to stay off his phone and he
could not stay on the phone he was
tweeting pictures of them a stone and
then they talked about what it happens
like they talked to the guy and is they
like did you give him the wrong envelope
what's going on and they're like you
gave her the wrong envelope and he just
went like no completely froze yeah it's
it's a it's just like a beat by beat
breakdown of like what happened how it
happened
yeah it's it is incredible
that that is just like the uh that's the
impossible thing happening like that is
naked gun literally made fun of that
yeah that's how impossible that event I
mean I'm not usually in favor of like
robots taking all of humans jobs but
that's one case where it's just like
just have an envelope holding robot
stage just drop it just a grocery store
you scan that just feeds it out of the
receipt oh yeah maybe man all right
let's keep going
I'd watching all drones Oscar you've
seen scenario of heroism in the face of
death now prepare for a movie about all
the talking that was going on at the
same time and get ready to see Gary
Oldman acting like you've never seen him
before in a fat suit he's a chameleon
I'll take wearing a fat suit to win an
Oscar over eating a bison liver or
something really bad like being Casey
Affleck yeah it'll be old man pause
great title man grumpy old grumpy old
man thank you yeah he's he's probably
gonna win yeah it's a Career Award I
mean he's good yeah that's the one I'm
not putting it back in my head this is
the one movie I didn't see darkest hour
yeah pretty much seen it okay it's
that's that's one of the better parts of
the that's him you know it's like it's
fine it's it's about it's weird how
things getting the zeitgeist though that
you have Dunkirk and in that movie which
is literally taking place during the
exact same time frame as Dunkirk like
literally it's it's the other side of
the pond of like having two volcano
movies come out yeah there's probably
also watching the crown at the same time
right which is really addressed
afterwards but it still got you know
with cows Churchill yeah
Churchill was very much yeah and it's
like guys yeah this year they definitely
deserve
best makeup obviously yeah the guy I
write I was listening to an interview
with the guy that did his makeup he's uh
I just lost his name in my head because
that's it I'm me and that's what I do
but he had retired from show business
like he did the grin she did all these
really like groundbreaking makeup things
and he
tired from show business and when they
started talking to Oldman about doing
this movie he called him it was like the
only reason the only way I'll do this
movie is if you come and do the suit so
he actually like came back to Hollywood
to do this Wow
well it looks good it's good-looking
suit yeah best assume that's a realistic
jiggle yep yep real I can feel the punch
keep God from visionary director
Guillermo del Toro who's contractually
obligated to be credited as visionary
director Guillermo del Toro comes a love
story between a woman and the fish
prisoner in her lab which sounds creepy
when you strip the art away from it but
trust me in the context of the story you
will totally be okay with this woman
having sex with a fish man it's actually
a really beautiful story about finding
your voice and it's calm for maenam from
known as a fish banging movie isn't it
it's my internal model so fish banging
movie yeah pause again I think I was
assigned the shape of water and that is
up that is very much my honest feelings
on this movie is it's a very beautiful
story about finding your voice and it
will forever be known it's good thoughts
on this are very clear and either is the
Best Picture winning fish banging movie
very likely yes I knew that this movie
would win Best Picture when I saw the
the fish in a movie theater appreciating
the beauty of cinema just like it
doesn't hurt alright that's the Oscar
reel is like but remember what's really
important our movies Guillermo del Toro
is immensely talented but he's also very
smart man yes and he knows the beats
they'll hit uh-huh and that's one of
them it's a good good movie though great
movie I love that one point the fish man
just looks at the camera is like you
know who else is important everyone in
Los Angeles but the post well we'll get
them personally I keep go
set during the great Italian church
shortage of 1983 between this grown man
and the seventeen-year-old
which also sounds creepy when you strip
the art away from it in this film full
of lush cinematography moving
performances and groundbreaking visual
effects that removed army hammers balls
from his short swords critics are saying
it's visually stunning transcendent and
one of the most mesmerizing films of the
year while the peach farmers association
is saying that's not why we grow them
but hey you do you low-heat of great
title then yeah good movie oh well
that's fun with it ya know the movie was
very clearly for me an adaptation of
like a novel or a short story or
whatever it was it felt very like
literary in the sense they was like not
too much happen but it was beautiful and
you just kind of were there for the
summer and it was performances are
strong yeah it felt like that there was
like clearly a lot of inner turmoil
going on that would be in a book or a
novel but this was just conveyed through
like looks and glances and and peach
humping we did did we did we toy with
calling this the peach banging I think
that's going with shape of water I think
maybe at that point we thought well
we'll get oh we also have deleted scenes
deleted titles and stuff like that I
think maybe got that we can stick around
you know that's in town of every
Missouri one wronged mother will write
injustice the only way she knows how
local advertising in a film with such
powerful performances you'll stop
referring to Sam Rockwell as that guy
and stop referring to him as that guy
you know from three billboards but three
racist inside every Missouri pause
that's our nod to the the controversy
around this movies that they don't
I guess narrative Lee account for the
fact that
Sam Rockwell's tortures a black person
in his custody and they just like well
they refer to it in a very offhand way
yeah and the movie never really circles
back to that yeah which I get it
I do see that point I also think that
it's probably it takes place inside
Epping Missouri yeah yeah it's a much
larger discussion than I think honest
trailer commentaries is equipped for but
I you know I went at for it when I first
heard the backlash I was like oh is it
just cuz what about you Golden Globes
and people's like no there's a whole
thing to it and I read it and it's
there's some great points and it's a
very vibrant healthy discussion yes but
I have no answer to yeah other than yeah
it's it's it's gonna win some Oscars
probably who was Sam Rockwell the guy
from before this movie for you guys for
me because I love the movie so much it's
confessions of a dangerous mind nice but
for most people is probably Iron Man 2
yeah always Justin Hammer dancing the
guy from The Green Mile
yeah the guy from Galaxy Quest is a
Galaxy was that guy in Galaxy Quest
his name was guy so technically he was
and still is guy from Galaxy Quest
yeah well there you go that guy remember
that guy you've seen him play historical
figures obsessed Mad Men and Hawkeye nah
not that one
the last Americans guy that's the one
witness Daniel day-lewis is stunning
farewell performance as an obsessed
craftsman who has trouble separating his
art from his personal life so Daniel
day-lewis some actor Method Man boss
yeah this is uh I think that the whole
thing is true for Paul Thomas Anderson
is well like he's a obsessive kind of
craftsman who is very hard to get under
the surface of and as fascinating read a
story that he this is based on true
events from his life sort of where he
was sick and his wife Maya Rudolph was
taking care of him and she was like he
was like she's very she's way nicer to
me well I'm sick she's really enjoying
this situation where I'm usually like a
little tyrant and she's being very sweet
to me like and from that grew this
really effed up relationship yeah
really must again this is a movie that I
really enjoyed I do think ya know they
Louis is my favorite headline that I saw
around this movie was something along
the lines of like Daniel day-lewis made
a dress from scratch for Fran tum'
thread because of course he did right
yeah it was there someone on a red
carpet like with a jacket on and they're
like ooh you wear he's like Daniel
day-lewis made this movie yeah thank you
seriously you can see his hands had like
little poke marks from from stitching
like this at my craft services furiously
sewing it yeah it's not fair you know
for other actors like he just becomes
the purse that person yeah that's it's
cool it's pretty cool it's like it's
like acting against morph from the x-men
animated series like I could pretend to
be this person but my competition is
this guy who just yes
yeah because we cast him as a guy who
cures cancer cures cancer I like that
cast Daniel day-lewis as a guy who does
something that is an immense help to
humanity because anyone's gonna get it
done
there will be you do it or he will die
trying for the art for the art or the
artful method
I think bring him in or it's like
quantum leap for real right a girl the
talented actor director so Indy you've
definitely pretended to know about her
already comes a note perfect
coming-of-age story about the most
difficult challenge a teenager can face
having to grow up in Sacramento I want
to go work Jasper was such a tough time
navigating her friendships boyfriends
and family you'll almost forgive her for
defending crash by the Dave Matthews
Band Who am I to talk I listen to Papa
Roach in high school put a bird on it
another layer to the epic voice guy
character onion he listened to Papa
Roach's yeah yeah I actually thought
that the music in this movie was so
perfect because it was it captures like
it actually doesn't try to be cool it
plays a lot of the like dumb on the nose
music from that era that like really
sets it in that time ya know what she
was high school and I was in high school
ladies freak dancing to crossroads by
both I related to that movie very well
because that was my toaster that was my
high school era yeah that was the music
of the day I know a lot of people like
like an old and she's may not way before
this but in a lot of areas like that
oh it's constant rotation you'll be
sticking in that rotation crash had him
bigger shelf license spam a crash was
the song that kept on giving through my
every year into college yeah me crash in
time of your life oh my god yeah yeah
what was the what was your Papa Roach
Jim
what was my Oh what was my pot Oh God
probably corn mmm-hmm we all had that
yes good em yeah 311 well your
California kid so probably 311 for you
more than corn maybe 311 and sublime
yeah which I was I will still stand
behind I was an angry redneck kids yeah
Corey space to me
that's jo-jo language is corn yeah that
is that's how people talk in Kentucky
right to each other just well have a
good alright then best director of all
time
according to every anonymous online Mary
comes a world war two stories so
visually beautiful so clinically brutal
and so needlessly out of sequence it
could only be made by Christopher Nolan
not everything has to be a puzzle box
Chris saving lots of privates oz yeah
I'm sure there are people that annoyed
that that's our take on Dunkirk that was
to be honest my take on Dunkirk was I
thought it was a stunningly crafted film
but the time thing and I get that's like
he was like well Christopher Nolan said
that he wanted to tell the night I get
that so Christopher Nolan said but as a
viewer for me I thought particularly as
the movie got toward the end that the
nonlinear narrative took the inherent
power and a lot of the danger out of the
story not that I just felt like you kind
of diffused things like you have the big
triumphant moment of the boats coming to
rescue people before you have the moment
of the it just it didn't the end didn't
work for me because you were paying off
moments it hadn't been set up properly
it just wasn't my preferred mode of
storytelling while I had no is that it
was a stunningly made film yeah I think
the same it was I think that across all
the three timelines it was designed to
ramp up the tension across you know over
the movie as a whole but since you're
jumping around in time like I didn't
know when to feel tense and when not to
because I didn't know where in time
exactly I had to remember like oh wait
no they're on their way to say after
they've gotten risky for the boat well
those guys are on the boat but they're
not on the boat they're out of the boat
here but they're back on the boat here
it was like okay well but if you cut
them to back in the boat that I've
already seen them outside of the boat
that I haven't seen oh they're gonna get
out of the boat so then the
conflict of them being in the boat is
diffused by the fact that I've already
seen him outside of the boat so yeah and
I got there but the point is that I had
to intellectualize my way there instead
of just feeling the you arrant like ah
tense I feel like it was nutshell it was
yeah it was the cost of like dramatic
tension and payoff for I see what you
did there I don't know it's a weird
decision to me it it I got his own way
on this one it was something that did
not work for me I felt that there was a
need to my sensibilities I felt it was a
needless complication it really fairly
straightforward story I think he could
have brought Tom Hardy and halfway
through the movie and layered all of
them together in a linear way just to
give that same kind of energetic kind of
charge to it but hey you know it's Nolan
he'll do he does what he does and a lot
of it so yeah a lot to like about that
movie and I think there are categories
where it deserves to win yeah but uh
saving lots of practice from two-time
Academy Award winning director Steven
Spielberg the Academy award-winning
writer of spotlight two-time Academy
Award winner Tom Hanks and twenty one
time Academy Award nominee Meryl Streep
comes a timely movie about the media
resisting an unpopular Republican
president in a film so calculated to win
Oscars they may as well have just put
Academy Award nominee in the title
Academy Award nominee the post if this
is a movie that feels engineered to win
yes sirs yeah and it didn't or won't
just not to the degree yeah yeah I'm
concerned about Spielberg like what was
he doing this time I mean it was okay
exactly but when you get that collection
of talent and it's just okay like this
is like you know the u.s. you know not
meddling it basketball or something it's
like you have clearly the best talent in
the world and like why aren't you
delivering yeah yeah part of it was just
I felt like because it was a very rushed
timeline I mean he put this thing
together yeah I have to make this movie
right now and so he got everybody
because he Steven Spielberg but there
were things that I felt like we're kind
of like he leaned into like John
Williams cuz there's like the uh but
it's like it's a newspaper machine
running yeah don't feel that it's that
John Williams whimsy it's like this is
there an alien that's gonna pass by on a
bicycle like I'm not
need that wimzie is not emotion I'm
looking and then I hated the spoiler
alert for history
hey the this setup of like oh I couldn't
go through this again oh it's just like
all right I get it
Watergate equally rushed and slept
through hmm if that makes it like weird
like manically rush but then also he was
completely asleep at the wheel which is
a weird like I don't know I enjoyed it
but again at the same time it just felt
like you know yeah I mean Spielberg
asleep at the wheel is still gonna be an
alright movie but yeah well obviously
you've got see the BFG but yeah it's it
seems kind of like I gotta get it was it
was Spielberg's version of mother he had
to get it out of his system and the way
that he does it is just whimsy and Tom
Hanks and we're all be so lucky are we
worried about Spielberg
I think tiny bit tiny bit we'll see how
ready player one ready player one I
think will be a kind of a watershed it's
gonna be a big moment we're worried
about Spielberg what's that
so what we're saying is we're worried
I've not know I think that I think that
the ready player one will be like kind
of a bellwether movie for where he's at
in his career I'm cashing my chips on
okay alright I think it's fun
we'll see yep great job in the teletrac
from the production company that is gone
from the Teen Choice Awards to the
Academy Awards comes the directing debut
of the player formerly known as Mouse
car in a horror thriller that holds a
mirror up to smug affluent white
progressives in other words the Academy
well it's an honor just to be nominated
right guys let the white ones in this
has a I think an outside chance of
getting Best Picture I actually think
that this is probably the forgive the
phrase Dark Horse like this is the
probably the second most likely for me I
can't see a reality where it does yeah
it would be third or fourth on my list I
think it would probably go ironically a
shape of water three billboards and then
maybe this movie but I could see a
reality
like it's I could see that happening
where if the vote is scattered
everywhere which it conceivably could be
that get out this way at the top of
everyone's near the top of everyone's
list and isn't that how they do it it's
it's ranked and preference yeah yeah
it's not like it's not pick one anymore
you have to rank them and then there are
certain points that are assigned to how
highly a movie is ranked so you know
that's right there behind yeah exactly
like moonlight probably potentially won
last year because it was a close rate
race between that wall and you know it's
very possible that it won because it had
a lot of two votes and lollol and had
some threes or fours and that just edged
out over the top I think it's a good way
of doing things to pick one you're
actually ranking a degree of preference
which is a like a good thing I think it
has a chance just because the fact that
it it came out before the ceremony last
year and it was even nominated at all
like that's the staying power of get out
it's had a re-release it's stayed in the
conversation so yeah I I see it as a
solid possible winner right I just think
that sure in the world at large I don't
even want to say love or hate it most
everybody loves it and especially in the
Academy like this is a movie that
everybody in that's a filmmaker or in
the filmmaking community likes and
respects
well that and to speak to the cynical
branch of the Academy and it exists it
is the perfect hybrid of a movie that is
actually really very good and also would
make them look very good and progressive
on a on a cultural level in the sense
that like you know they would get a lot
of Pat's on the back from people and I'm
not saying it doesn't deserve it because
if get out won Best Picture
that'd be great I would love to see not
just because get out is a great movie
just for its message and what it says
but because it's just a great bit I love
seeing a genre movie that can actually
succeed and it also have the added
effect for Academy members of people
going like look at Best Picture it's
also a year where and it there isn't
it wouldn't be I don't think it would be
an upset because there's no clear
favorite there's really not which I love
yeah well there's no clear best picture
for you to two years like it's so much
because like I like rooting for and
against films but this time I'm just
good I'm shooting for Mad Max two years
ago yeah I thought it might pull it off
because it won so many yeah but I like
spotlight and I was just glad the
revenant didn't
yes that was my we get it the Sun sets
it happens every day is beautiful guys
never been outside all right let's give
you a story the following comic book
whoo Oh nursery pause for a second we
should should we pull the curtain back
on this well we had an idea that didn't
work out yeah we were gonna have a
special guest yeah couldn't for
scheduling reasons appear but will
perhaps be working with us in the future
on something else hopefully very soon so
this is kind of a that last minute cuz
you'd written this as a backup but we
had to cut it implement this at the last
minute because we had to make an
alternate plan toward what the ending
was gonna be it was a very different
ending but anyone that we were excited
about but it's one of those things that
just couldn't happen which I think we'll
be able to talk more about what's we do
the other things yeah let's let's save
the surprise because we will be working
with this person shortly in the future
yeah and then we'll be back maybe next
week that what happened so you've been
maybe we can do a staged reading of oh
all right stay tuned a teaser watch our
B matter thor ragnarok for best go boom
Wonder Woman for Best two-thirds of a
movie Justice League for Best Picture
but only the Snyder card woken for Best
Picture for people who only sell comic
book movies last year guardians to four
best movers would that immediately
forgot about an accomplice spider-man
home cover and by the best lack of an
origin story and guardians for best
Russian superhero movie I only saw a
trailer for but holy SH one of them
turns into a bear and I miss this one
the Oscars van with all the sexual
harassment exposed this year this is
gonna be a really sensitive emotional
ceremony
take it away host of the man show boy
you guys excited about seeing a few
girls jump on trampolines Wow
different time different time Maxim mag
and Spike TV Spike TV an Imagi man show
and weird show what a time to be 14
Corolla had like switched career
trajectories and like Corolla was now
the guy with a late night show like
yelling Trump every night and hosting
the Academy Awards and Kimmel was like
here's what I don't like about Mexican
people yeah what happened he was
building tables live on TV last time I
saw him I don't know what the show was
it was like literally like Adam Corolla
builds tables with his friends and they
were just okay building building stuff I
want to get my career where someone's
like you got a project in mind and I'm
like I want to build a table with some
friends of mine on national television
deal wife LA I'm serious like nothing's
more fascinating than live stream live
furniture construction live carpentry
yeah what skill would you demonstrate
live on a late-night talk show oh man I
would I would try to learn to dance I
would try to ballroom dance it's good
yeah all right I won't ask you dad I
know you you know I'm not gonna movie
yeah so you would not try to ballroom
day no I would not see let's watch some
deleted scenes yes
critics are saying it's visually
stunning transcendent and one of the
most mesmerizing films of the year and
audiences say oh yeah isn't that the
movie where Armie Hammer dances that
movie were Armie Hammer dancer Italian
Pie featuring Ali performance so good
there's no way you'll ever pronounce
crse Ronan's name wrong ever again ha ha
I just did it again didn't I find out
Joe dang it call me by your nickname I
like that
Golden State cast away the nutty prime
minister the most Oscar winners in one
movie we won all titles russia's arial
arial font kill billboards as a reform
go to this time bow trip rises boat trip
maven going to go with yeah that's
pretty good
well the thing we didn't call out in
Dunkirk was I was just so impressed by
British people's ability to stay in line
or a cue what's going on around you
there's literally bombs exploding and
they're like well yep just stick with it
lads
right after the other I've got to donate
this sack of aluminium oh no not again
no Joe don't say the word all right guys
yeah this has been fun we've done yeah I
hope you do it again next to here we're
probably not gonna do the Emmys again
because I was their lowest rated on his
trailer it was but I like doing these
mini ones they're fun they are fun
little quick hits jabs yeah maybe we'll
start doing mini honest trailers be a
lot less work for us it would be really
we cut our workload and like a third so
like here's the four movies that came
out in January
yeah got it but sucks for the editors
yes
no really hard on Robert a Hopi our
graphics guy and super hard on the
editor so our law our game would be
their loss or vice versa
so but hey whatever hey whatever you
guys are great
and you got a good Robert
are you watching a great hope you join
us next week for something that's gonna
really Rock
[Laughter]
[Music]
you